the first problem is to prove the good
mother Gothel theorem which is that the
expected characteristic polynomial the
signed adjacency matrix is the matching
polynomial so the thing is I suspect
some of you many of you might have seen
the proof so I would like to solicit
ideas from those who have not seen it
talk about it now
yes sir is there anybody who has not
seen it yes oh great okay great
can you get all the permutations over
that corresponds to computing the
determinant yeah so you have to pick
both edges both entries in the matrix
corresponding to an end if you want if
you don't want to turn to cancel out
because otherwise you we have minus one
and plus one for each of them yeah well
yeah so would you like to volunteer all
right should I prove my stereo not to
come here or I don't know so we have
this matrix right we have axis diagonal
then we have this minus
yeah so it's - these are plus minus ones
right SUV is plus minus one symmetric
yeah they're both minuses I think it's
correct but I I think it's okay let's
see so okay so what kind of permutation
can contribute to this so let's let's
see what kinds of permutations actually
cancel out if you had a claim about that
if there is some edge that termination
only has one of its entries in this
matrix then we're hunting so that the
product of so
yes otherwise you're counting you must
have both yeah there's some oh I mean
there's some interesting today I don't
know exactly yeah
so you have some edges and you have some
entries on the diagonal which are
actually the vertices not covered by the
matching right it must be matching
because it's a permutation which
consists of two cycles and fixed points
so let's actually verify this you are
suspicious but I think it's yeah so to
the contribution permutation I
consisting of two cycles the two cycles
must form a matching so they correspond
to a matching that's really perfect and
then we have some one cycles which are
those are the vertices not covered by
the matching right so this permutation
in expectation contributes X to the
number of uncovered
RTC's times sign of the permutation
which is actually the number of two
cycles each two cycle will flip this
it
I think that's it yeah thank you thank
you a second exercise it is the
direction of Belle's
theorem which we did not rule which is
that if F and G have a common
interlacing then every convex
combination is real rooted so this is
simpler to prove I a little hint it's
simpler to prove when you assume that
there are no multiple routes multiple
routes are slightly annoying you have to
think about what to do with them but
let's solve it first in the case where
you don't have multiple routes and then
let's say something about
this actually has a nice proof by
picture
don't you have to assume that the
highest decisions have the same sign or
something
Oh correct so it was in the slides I
think but we have we should assume let's
assume they're both morning the leading
coefficient is just one
then they change sign as they should
yep
you have a solution yes but you will
withhold it for now
[Music]
a younger crowd what we might do so we
have two polynomials they have a common
interlacing and remember the picture it
means that oscillate in a consistent way
let's assume for now that they have n
distinct roots each other
[Music]
sighs yeah yeah they change signs in the
same way yes yes yes so uh would you
like to still so young do you want to
come up to the board no you refuse okay
well okay so yeah so if we assume that
they have n simple roots then indeed
it's pretty clean so let's say let me
actually follow the convention from the
slides that we have a blue polynomial we
have these black separation points on
the real line red polynomial which
oscillates which crosses the real axis
between the black points as it should
similar to the blue polynomial okay so
now when you evaluate these polynomials
and the black rule at the black points
but also assume that these black points
are actually not the roots themselves
and the roots are strictly between them
then we see that the sign of the blue
polynomial and the red polynomial I
believe that's what you mean
alternates in the same fashion so it's
because they were assumed to be both
leading coefficient 1 and plus infinity
direction they have to go to plus
infinity so here it should be plus 1 it
should be plus sign is plus there is
minus minus and now we take a convex
combination right so if you take a
convex combination the signs still are
still flip in exactly the same fashion
so so the signs of H T of X which is a
convex combination
they alternate the same fashion so
because of the degree and the number of
times it goes up and down we know that
it must actually cross the real axis
exactly once between each pair of black
points because we have certain degree
and this red-and-blue polynomial they
they have n distinct roots and so will
this averaged point o me all right so
now this slightly annoying question of
multiple roots does somebody have clean
suggestion how to deal with the case of
multiple roots we want to make the same
statement what can happen with multiple
roots is that for example these black
points we could have several of them
might coincide and then we have is blue
and red roots they could be squeezed
together into one point and you could
have a bunch of roots in the same okay
so how do you deal with that you need
some say that this is okay yes well so
it's a little okay so for example you
could have a double root of one of the
two polynomials and it could be a triple
root of the other one and the
interlacing could still be okay when you
think about it so okay so yeah so what
is your yeah what is the suggestion
what I'd like to do is just factor out
an upcoming routes that we reduce to
this case so even a double room okay so
there's a distinction here between
shared roofs and multiples so they could
have shared the routes but also maybe
the routes are not shared at all
maybe polynomial has double route so
then and what happens you have to say
something
I guess it's impossible that 1.0 meal
has a double root and the other
polynomial doesn't have any route you
have to be careful and it gets kind of
messy when you start classifying huh
okay okay yes Wow so we could if you do
it carefully yes yes wash them so you
have to push them carefully yeah so the
definition of the grease were assumed to
be the same they have a common
interlacing yeah that's the difference
yeah it's not that F interlaces G but F
and G have a common interlacing but I
think it's still true the two points can
be same ever they could be so if you
have according to the definition they
could be a so the definition maybe I
should tell you what the differential so
and I hope it's the correct definition
so the definition common interlacing
literally saying means that alpha K and
beta K are both in a closed interval K
minus one must recall then the root
sorry then you should have yes so if two
gammas are equal then you should have
both alpha root and a beta root in there
coinciding with that yeah it could be a
mass because you could have another root
of like one of the polynomials could
have a double root but maybe maybe the
the F is only single root and G it's a
double root I still you know I would
like to come back to your suggestion
which was which was to tweak it to avoid
this situation and maybe you can
classify all these situations it's
certainly possible because the results
should be true but I I don't see a very
clean way to do it actually one-shot
argument that says how to handle all
these coin side possibly coinciding
multiple rules
so you perturb it yes yes
so you had okay would you like to
volunteer yeah I think the only clean
way there are different ways to perturb
it but I think the solution is to tweak
the polynomial so that they actually
have distinct singular roots and then
you use a limiting argument you have to
tweak them oh no I mean I mean you can
you can have a sequence of polynomials
that converges to F converges to G so
the convex combinations will converge
I'm not sure if you have to be
particularly careful about perturbing
the roots actually I think here I I
don't know there there might be
different ways to pattern them for me
the easiest ways to think about actually
perturbing the roots themselves you just
push the roots apart a little bit so
still come in this depression from thank
you so what it exactly is alpha sub K
alpha sub K is the Keith's largest root
I think that's if they're three oh them
when siding roots then you can just
label them I mean this is clear so so f
has the roots has a roots alpha
so when you say alpha sub K is the left
interval so then some other route so
it's a real rooted point on me so I can
label the roots okay
ordered way and then I say there exists
the real numbers in gamma K such that
the K through top F and also the K
through of G are in this interval so I
think it's pretty clear so if F and G
have no common roots all the gamma is a
indeed all the gamma is a distinct right
- G has no common these are two
different things common roots and so
you're saying you're saying it's
possible to choose the gammas so that
they are distinct I'm saying if you
assume that F and G have no common yes
okay okay that's true true yes so now
once the gamma is a distinct this proof
follows through because at every kunai F
and both F and G cannot be zero so at
least one out of F and G have to have a
has to have a sign and the other either
at the first first point one has to be
positive and the other one can be at
most zero C has to be positive okay yeah
every strict convex combination same for
the next one at least one of them has to
be negative
that's a commonly I think that's fine
yeah we just have to take out the shared
route so let me try to write it down
then you have to say how you put the
shared routes and if there are shared
groups then we just divide them well
well you divide them but when you put
them back in you have to say what you do
that well I just need to prove that FNG
or linear combinations of F and G are
interlacing with a real rooted real root
tip so you factor out then you add Amica
it's still a real rooted yes so there
was one additional claim which we used
later which was that the convex
combination is still consistent with the
same interlacing points which was useful
for which was important although there
might be other ways to prove it but I
used it to argue about the maximum root
which was but I think yeah let's let's
forget that point I think you have a
nice solution so remove shared roots
then these must be distinct points
because if not then these fools would
have to be double of length zero so they
would be the same route that's good and
and then your next claim was that it's
not possible that both F and G are zero
[Music]
hi and that was because it would be a
shared route right so so the signs of h
TX alternate okay thank you that's nice
yeah so I think we can
[Applause]